[Musique]
orschwihr petite commune viticole du
haut rhin les 800 habitants ne parle
plus que de cela
jugez plutôt les cocoricos intempestifs
de ce coq jusque là de nous ont été
déclarés coupables de troubler le
sommeil du voisinage je trouve que c'est
elle commence à chanter à 4 du menton
s'agirait-il d'un coq insomniaques un
possible déclare le propriétaire tout le
monde tous les éleveurs savent qu en
coupe ne chante pas la nuit et il n'y a
pas de lumière sur la route la nuit donc
on peut pas dire le zèle numérique crois
que j'ai les jours et commence à chanter
quand le jour se lève comme un coq en
pâte au milieu de sa basse-cour ce
gallinacé est en passe de devenir la
coqueluche du village
même le conseil municipal est venu lui
apporter son soutien
donc on n'a pas une race qu'aucune
chante pas d'ailleurs c'est l'emblème
l'emblème de la france les cocoricos
français sont réputés en europe et dans
le monde entier
emblème français ou pas ce coq a déjà
coûté son propriétaire 2300 francs de
frais de justice et 100 francs par jour
de cocorico à ce tarif là pas question
d'en faire un coq au riesling passera un
jour certainement à la casserole mais
certainement pas à ce qu'il veut par
jugement tribune de des tribunaux n'ont
comme diraient certains
on vit décidément une époque formidable
[Musique]